[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live da
comunidade fechada.
Hoje nós temos seis perguntas, temos bem
menos perguntas do que na semana
passada.
Então, a gente vai poder discutir um
artigo ou dois aqui,
já que temos tempo.
Bem, a primeira pergunta na reposição
hormonal com creme bioidêntico, é
necessário manter o mesmo local e
horário de aplicação?
Bem, o local é bom alternar. Por
exemplo, se você passa na coxa
direita num dia, no dia seguinte é bom
passar na coxa esquerda.
Então é interessante fazer essa essa
essa alternação para aumentar a
absorção.
Agora existe sim alguns produtos que
pedem para não mudar o local de
aplicação. A região interna das coxas é
uma região boa para absorção, mas então
eu recomendo um dia fazer do lado
direito, outro dia fazer do lado
esquerdo.
O horário tem que ser sempre o mesmo
para poder manter níveis hormonais mais
estáveis e evitar flutuações.
E também importante, se a pessoa for
tomar banho, ela tomar banho primeiro e
depois aplicar e não ao contrário, né?
Então, se ela for fazer
a questão do banho e ela esquecer de
aplicar antes do banho,
aí é melhor ela esperar pelo menos aí eh
2 horas para poder tomar o banho depois
que aplicou o creme.
Existe também um um truque, né, de você
passar um creme hidratante uma meia hora
antes de aplicar o creme. Em muitos
casos isso também aumenta o local,
aumenta a taxa de absorção do do creme
ou do gel, né?
É importante evitar áreas com pele
espessa. Hoje mesmo atendi uma paciente
que tava aplicando no pé, né? O pé não é
um lugar bom para aplicar esses cremes
transdérmicos, tá?
E sempre opte por regiões que tenha
pouca pilificação, ou seja, poucos pelos
e que a pele não esteja irritada. E
tente espalhar o creme numa área ampla
para garantir uma absorção adequada.
Eu
acho que é basicamente isso. Não tô
lembrando mais de nada agora. Qual seria
o melhor tratamento para síndrome de
ativação mastocitária? Isso é uma
situação difícil de tratar. Só foi
reconhecido isso recentemente.
Eu comecei a falar desse assunto em
2022. É uma coisa nova.
E o tratamento dessa síndrome visa tanto
o controle dos sintomas
quanto a prevenção das crises.
Então, o manejo dessa situação tem que
ser sempre individualizado, levando em
conta os sintomas predominantes, quais
são os gatilhos que foram identificados
e também as doenças de base.
Então, primeiro, identificar os
gatilhos, que pode ser alimentos,
geralmente são alimentos,
mas pode ser também medicamentos, pode
ser estresse, pode ser infecções ou
temperaturas extremas.
E é muito importante o paciente se
tornar especialista
no próprio tratamento, que tenha um
conhecimento muito bom da sua condição,
porque é uma situação muito difícil de
tratar.
Quais são os tratamentos farmacológicos,
né? bloqueador estamínico que pode ser
natural ou farmacológico, né? Dos que
são utilizados frequentemente da
farmácia como é cetilisina e
aloratadina, mas dos naturais você pode
estar utilizando a combinação de
quecetina com vitamina C.
Também pode usar bromelina e papaína
também ajuda.
Também utilizamos antihistamínicos da
classe H2, né, que é são os antigos
remédios de estômago, que hoje usa muito
pouco para estômago, mas serve para
bloquear
esse receptor estamínico do tipo dois.
Eles também são particularmente
interessantes quando existe predomínio
de sintomas gastrointestinais.
Aí é o caso da famidina no Brasil. Hanit
não encontra mais para para comprar nas
farmácias.
Nós temos também os estabilizadores de
mastócitos,
que é o cromoglicato de sódio e o
cetotifeno.
Então eles ajudam a prevenir a liberação
de medida mediadores, né, inflamatórios.
Nós também temos os antileucotrienos,
que é o caso do montelucaste e do
zileon.
Então ele ajuda a controlar os sintomas
respiratórios e gastrointestinais.
Em alguns casos você pode utilizar
anti-inflamatórios não esteroidais, como
é o caso do AS, ácido acetil salicílico,
que é para controlar o rubor e os
sintomas vasomotores.
Em alguns casos, você pode usar
corticoesteroides. Aí eu só sugiro esse
uso em casos graves ou refratários. Aí
você pode usar predinisona, por exemplo,
ou outros, como é o caso da
fudrocortisona,
é o caso também da prednisolona,
tem vários aí, né?
Para casos muito graves ou refratários,
existe um anticorpo monoclonal que é omá
lisumab, né? Mas é muito caro e deve ser
só selecionado para casos refratários do
tratamento convencional.
E é muito importante, além dos remédios
que eu acabei de comentar, você ficar
longe dos fatores, né, gatilhos, como eu
comentei, principalmente reduzir os
alimentos ricos em estamina e também
cortar os medicamentos que possam
liberar estamina.
Já falei da vitamina C da quecetina como
agentes naturais interessantes para
ajudar a controlar liberação de estamina
e téc de relaxamento e de manejo do
estress também são muito importantes.
E alguns pacientes têm rações tão
fortes, né, de liberação de estamina que
chega a parecer uma anafilaxia. E nesses
casos você tem que utilizar a canetinha
de pinefrina ou adrenalina, né, como se
fosse realmente uma reação alérgica
muito forte.
Próxima pergunta. Deixa eu ver se tá
aparecendo bem aqui.
Em linhas gerais, eh, qual é deve ser a
dieta de uma pessoa que sofre de
pancreatite? Deixa eu aumentar o tamanho
aqui da ficar mais fácil vocês lerem.
Bem, eu tô imaginando que a pergunta é
relativa a pancreatite crônica, né?
Porque a pancreatite aguda a pessoa vai
ficar de jejum, né? Ela vai ficar de
jejum, então nem se aplica a dieta aqui.
Mas a ideia é reduzir a sobrecarga do
pâncreas, evitar crises subsequentes,
né? Uma pancreatite recidivante, né? Que
a gente chama de subaguda
e garantir a nutrição adequada. Então,
geralmente na na medicina ortodoxa se
pede para baixar o teor de gordura. A
principal recomendação seria manter uma
dieta pobre em gordura, porque os
alimentos gordurosos exigem maior
esforço do pâncreas paraa digestão.
A frequência das refeições é solicitado
que seja mais frequente, né? Pequenas
refeições distribuídas ao longo do dia,
cinco a seis refeições menores, em vez
de grandes volumes de comida de uma vez.
evitar o consumo de álcool, porque
estaria associado a pior da pancreatite.
Isso é meio óbvio. Evitar os alimentos
processados e ricos em açúcares. É o
caso aí de dos alimentos
industrializados.
Eles também geralmente são ricos em
gorduras saturadas, então devem ser
evitados para não sobrecarregar o órgão
evitar picos de triglicerides no sangue.
Então, os alimentos recomendados são
carnes magras, como peito de frango,
peixe, peru, ovos, né, só que mais as
claras, laticínios desnatados,
eh, seria leite desnatado, iogurte
light, queijos brancos magros, grãos
integrais como arroz integral, aveia,
pão integral e massas integrais e
quinoa. Aqui eu tô falando da medicina
ortodoxa, tá? Vocês sabem que eu não
gosto de pão e derivados do leite.
Legumes e verduras. preferir cozidos,
especialmente em fases agudas para
facilitar a digestão. Frutas sem casca e
sem sementes, especialmente cozidas ou
assadas nas fases de maior
sensibilidade.
Fontes vegetais de proteína como
feijões, lentilhas, grão de bico em
pequenas quantidades e bem cozidos,
gorduras saudáveis em moderação,
pequenas quantidades de azeite de oliva,
óleo de coco, abacate.
Então você pode utilizar essas gorduras
boas com tanto que não exagere.
Então, alimentos a evitar são frituras,
alimentos muito gordurosos, como carnes
gordas, embutidos, bacon, linguiça,
manteiga, creme de leite, queijos
amarelos, fast food, salgadinho, batata
frita, maionese, molhos prontos,
sorvetes e doces cremosos, doces e
açúcares simples como bolos, biscoitos,
balas, refrigerantes, sucos
industrializados, sobremesas açucaradas,
bebidas alcoólicas como cerveja, vinho
destilados e licores,
eh, alimentos como hambúrgueres, pizzas
prontas, lasanhas, refeições
instantâneas,
laticínios integrais, como leite
integral, iogurtes integrais e queijos
amarelos, nozes e sementes em excesso,
né, são saudáveis, mas são fontes de
gordura e deve ser consumida com
moderação para quem tem pancreatite
crônica.
Devido à má absorção de nutrientes, os
portadores de pancreatite crônica devem
fazer reposição ou suplementação de
vitaminas liposolúveis A, D, E
também de minerais sob orientação
nutricional e médica. Hidratação
importante, boa ingestão de líquidos,
preferencialmente água, chás e água de
coco. E o acompanhamento nutricional
também é muito importante. Então,
exemplo de café da manhã, um pão
integral sem glúte com ricota, um suco
de fruta natural, o lanche da manhã,
fruta cozida ou assada, um almoço, peito
de frango grelhado, mais arroz integral,
mais legumes cozidos, o lanche da tarde,
um iogurte desnatado. E o jantar é uma
sopa de legumes com peixe desfiado, tá?
Então, exemplos aí para vocês. Qual que
é a dose ideal e segura do Red East
Rice?
O Red East Rice também é conhecido como,
né, monácos purpúrios, né, é o nome lá
do do do levedura do fungo, né?
E na farmácia você vai encontrar ele com
o nome de,
agora esqueci o nome no comercial, daqui
a pouco eu lembro, né? Mas a dose mais
comum recomendada pelos fabricantes é de
2400 mg
por dia. Geralmente dividido em duas
doses 1200 mg.
E existe também aqui no Brasil esse
produto monácicos purpúrios, né? Eh,
tentando lembrar o nome do remédio.
Deixa eu olhar aqui rapidamente.
Ah.
Tô olhando aqui o nome comercial que me
fugiu. É o Monales, tá?
Então no Brasil o Monales é em 600 mg
geralmente, né? Então você tomaria duas
cápsulas de 600 mg duas vezes ao dia.
Então os estudos clínicos avaliaram uma
ampla faixa de dosagens, começando com
600 mg duas vezes ao dia para 1200 mg
duas vezes ao dia e até chegando a 3600
mg por dia.
O componente ativo do redis rice, né, do
monascos, é o monacolin k, que é
equivalente à lovatina
e a dosagem efetiva deve considerar o
conteúdo de monacolinc, né?
Precauções importantes, né? não deve ser
utilizado em mulheres grávidas ou
amamentando, nem crianças menores de 18
anos, nem adultos acima de 70 anos e não
deve ser utilizado em concomitância com
a estatina. Deve ser feito o
monitoramento de função do fígado e
também a parte muscular, porque ele tem
os mesmos efeitos colaterais das
estatinas
e preferencialmente utilizar junto com
com enzima Q10 para prevenir
deficiência, como é o caso das
estatinas.
Bem, próxima pergunta.
Doutor, para próstata no valor limítrofe
de 30 g de peso, seria o caso utilizar
finasterida 5 mg para evitar o
crescimento?
O a dosagem de finasterida poderia ser
menor? Caso positivo, o objetivo é
reduzir o DHT para algum valor
específico com a financiaida.
Boa pergunta, né? Mas se a próstata
desse tamanho que é muito pouco
aumentada, eu não utilizaria
finasterida, não, tá? Eh, eu acho que o
risco aí não compensa,
a não ser que a pessoa já tenha tido uma
experiência anterior com finasterida
para cabelo, por exemplo, de 1 mg e não
teve nenhum efeito colateral. Aí poderia
usar uma finasteria de 1 mg para
prevenção, mas eu preferiria utilizar o
sal palmeto, tiga de oica e o pig
africano como uma maneira preventiva e
não utilizar finasterida, que tem bem
mais efeitos colaterais, tem risco lá da
síndrome pósfasterida.
Então, se eu fosse te dizer, tem certeza
que você não tem reação finasterida,
utilizaria 1 mg por dia para uma próça
desse tamanho, mas eu preferia utilizar
os naturais.
A gente geralmente não utiliza o DHT
como critério, tá? para definir dose.
Seria até interessante, mas não não
existe essa
diretriz de usar o DHT para guiar o
tratamento.
Lembrando que a fin de média reduz a
prósta em aproximadamente 20%. Isso na
dose de 5 mg
e demora alguns meses para ter melhora a
significativa do jato urinário e o PSA
reduz
os valores em aproximadamente 50%.
Os estudos então não estabeleceram um
valor específico de DHT como objetivo
terapêutico, tá? Como eu já disse
anteriormente,
e o monitoramento se baseia na clínica,
na melhora dos sintomas urinários, no
score e PSS,
e também na urofluxometria, com aumento
do fluxo urinário máximo
e na redução do volume prostático.
Próxima pergunta. produtor para cálculo
renal de 6 mm alojado no rim. Caso não
ocorra eliminação natural em algumas
semanas, a chance seria menos mais ou
menos 50%. Seria possível realizar a
litotripsia obrigatório realizar o
procedimento pela uretra para retirar do
cálculo.
Então, para esses casos, né, alguns anos
atrás era muito indicado fazer a
litotrípse extracorpórea, né? Ela foi
caindo em desuso com o tempo e foi
aumentado as indicações de fazer
uretero, renolitotreia
flexível com laser.
Então, pra cálculo de 6 mm, cálculo
renal, as taxas de eliminação natural
são aproximadamente 33%
espontâneo e 60% de chance para cálculos
ah entre 4 a 6 mm. Segundo algumas
fontes,
o tempo médio para eliminação natural
desses cálculos na faixa de 4 a 6 mm é
de 45 dias.
Então, como eu falei, a litotrípic
extracorpora era a opção mais utilizada
até alguns anos atrás para cálculos
desse tamanho dentro do rim.
A eficácia varia muito, mas existe
relatos de 80 a 90% de eficácia em 3
meses.
Então, a taxa de eliminação completa
entre 55 e 85%.
E não necessita internação, fica mais ou
menos meio-dia no hospital.
A ureteroscopia flexível, como eu falei,
reno
flexível com o laser, aumentou muito a
indicação nos últimos anos,
tem uma taxa maior de sucesso
comparada com a litra corpórea,
mas aí teria que passar o aparelho por
dentro da uretra, dentro da bexiga,
dentro do uretério até chegar até o rim,
tá?
Aí seria
o que você não queria fazer.
Então, geralmente se opta pelo pela
litotrípice extracorpó quando o cálculo
ele não é muito grande nessa faixa 6 mm
seria uma boa indicação. E quando ele tá
no cálice médio ou no cálice superior,
se ele tiver no cálice inferior,
geralmente é melhor fazer a uretero reno
endoscópica.
Bem, já foram as seis perguntas. Ah,
sim, temos a Maria Helena presente na
live. Tem mais alguém me escutando? Só
Maria Helena.
Já temos mais ou menos meia hora de
live. Até um pouco menos, mas eu não
tinha visto ninguém entrar até agora a
pouco, até às 7:30 da noite.
Sim, Maria Helena, eh, quer fazer a
pergunta? Pode fazer.
Eu já respondi as seis perguntas. Hã,
você
fez uma pergunta sua aqui no no
documento, né? Ah, não, ela vai fazer
agora a pergunta. Se tomar o para
deitar, pode tomar zeita para que ela
possa recolher o lixo do organismo na
madrugada?
Sim, você pode tomar os dois juntos.
Sim.
Não quero parar o ao deitar ou terei que
ingerir na no jantar. Não, você pode
tomar junto, né? O problema do zeita é
que você não deve tomar ele junto com
suplemento, tá? Quando eu falo
suplemento, é mais no sentido do ser
fitoterápico, algum remédio natural,
porque ele pode bloquear a ação, porque
ele pode bloquear ação desse
fitoterápico. Agora, no caso do
aminoácido
do E protein, até que pode atrapalhar um
pouquinho a absorção do E protein, mas
não é uma coisa que vai fazer tanta
diferença. Se você puder tomar o protein
e esperar para tomar o zeita, tipo, uma
meia hora depois, é melhor, tá?
Boa noite, Denise. Tem alguma pergunta
ao vivo?
Ah, sim. Mas é nesse caso você tem que
dar o intervalo. Você pode tomar
melatonina,
ultrogestã
e tomar também o E aí espera meia hora e
aí que você vai tomar o zeita. Melhor
você fazer assim, tá? Para não
atrapalhar a absorção da melatonina no
gestã.
De nada. Espero que tenha ficado claro.
Deixa eu achar um artigo aqui pra gente
discutir.
Ah. Tem um artigo bem recente,
interessante aqui, como comer de mais
comidas inadequadas, né? O junk food,
né? O fast food pode afetar a função
cerebral.
Foi um estudo com 29 homens jovens sem
problemas de saúde conhecidos, que tinha
há de comer muito fast food, alimentos
ultraprocessados
e eles comeram esse tipo de alimentação
por c dias consecutivos
e isso alterou a responsividade
do cérebro à insulina.
também reduziu a sensação de
recompensa cerebral e aumentou o a
gordura do fígado.
Olha só como é que a medicina ortodoxa
já está reconhecendo
que essas comidas alteram o
funcionamento cerebral.
A resistência eh insulínica cerebral,
ela reduz a sinalização cognitiva
relacionado à ingesta de comida e a
memória.
Então esse estudo ele é muito importante
porque ele dá mais dados sobre um corpo
crescente de literatura, de como o
cérebro rapidamente ele percebe e reage
a mudanças dietéticas e sugere que essas
mudanças podem persistir
após que a mudança dietética ela é
interrompida.
Então é muito importante ter hábitos
dietéticos consistentes
para manter a função cerebral.
Ah, Denise, que bom, porque a maioria do
pessoal acaba mandando um monte de
pergunta, né?
E acaba que a gente fica muito focado
nas perguntas, né?
Nesse estudo, o que que foi identificado
em relação ao hipocampo?
Ele foi uma das regiões cerebrais mais
afetadas pela alimentação inadequada.
E mesmo uma semana depois de voltar a
comer direitinho, depois de comer os
cinco dias de fast food, o estrago ainda
continuava. Então não voltou normal
rapidamente. Vai demorar mais de uma
semana para melhorar.
Em relação ao fígado, né? O fígado dos
jovens acumulou gordura em apenas 5 dias
comendo essa dieta ruim.
Então isso tem muito a ver com o
microbioma intestinal, que eles
trilhões de bactérias boas que vivem no
nosso intestino. Então os
ultraprocessados
surgiram como se fosse uma bomba
atômica, né, para as bactérias boas.
Acabaram matando as bactérias do bem e
alimentando as bactérias do mal.
Existe um círculo vicioso no cérebro que
fica viciado nessas junk foods.
As bactérias ruins mandam mensagem pro
cérebro dizendo: "Queremos mais
pocaria". O cérebro já meio viciado e
também zonzo pela resistência insulínica
obedece, né? e cria essa questão da
compulsão
e os emulsificantes, corantes,
conservantes acabam aumentando a
permeabilidade intestinal.
Nós sabemos que as empresas que produzem
esses alimentos processados,
elas gastam milhões para deixar esse
produtos com sabor perfeito para as
pessoas não conseguirem parar de comer.
E estudos brasileiros mostraram que quem
come mais de 20% das calorias diárias em
ultraprocessados,
o que dá umas 400 calorias numa dieta de
2.000,
já tem um declínio cognitivo 28% mais
rápido.
Então, o período para começar a melhorar
é acima de 10 dias da melhora da dieta.
Vamos ver mais um artigo aqui.
Tem um estudo bem interessante aqui de
uma metaanálise comparando vários tipos
de dietas
para verificar qual seria melhor para o
envelhecimento saudável.
Então, esse estudo que eu tô comentando
agora é um estudo muito grande. Foram
100.000 pessoas estudadas durante 30
anos. Um estudo bem grande mesmo que
para tentar descobrir a forma como a
gente come, como ela pode literalmente
dobrar nossa chance de envelhecer com
saúde.
Então os pesquisadores pegaram oito
dietas diferentes,
não foi só uma dieta milagrosa
e todas elas mostraram resultados
impressionantes. A campeã de todas as
dietas foi uma dieta que eu nem conhecia
chamado A I, né? índice de alimentação
saudável alternativo.
E quem seguiu essa dieta teve 86% mais
chance em chegar aos 70 anos sem doenças
crônicas.
É um número bem alto, né?
Então, o que que essas dietas têm todas
em comum? Todas elas pedem pra gente
caprichar nas frutas, verduras, grãos
integrais, castanhas
e manerar nos ultraprocessados.
a dieta mind, né, que é uma variação da
dieta DASH,
ela junta o melhor da dieta mediterrânea
com a dieta DAS, que é uma dieta que foi
desenvolvida para hipertensão arterial
e o foco dela seria proteger nosso
cérebro.
Então, estudos mostram que quem segue
essa dieta mind pode ter um cérebro
funcionando como se fosse 7 anos e meio
mais jovem.
A National Geographic publicou
recentemente que mesmo começando tarde
na vida, a seguir a dieta Mind reduz em
25% o risco de demência.
Um em cada quatro casos pode ser
evitado.
Então o essas dietas pedem para fazer
uso de vegetais de folhas verdes
escuras, tipo espinafre, couve e rúcula,
frutas vermelhas como morango, amora e
mirtilo, que são frutas antioxidantes,
azeite de oliva extrav, castanhas, nozes
e grãos integrais e peixe, especialmente
a sardinha.
E como eu falo para meus pacientes,
quanto mais colorido o prato, melhor.
Cada cor representa diferentes
fitoquímicos, né? Diferentes
substâncias boas para as bactérias do
intestino.
Diferentes polifenóis
são compostos bioativos que agem com
verdadeiros remédios.
e vão combater a inflamação e proteger
nossas células da oxidação.
O Jeffrey Blend, que é o pai da medicina
funcional americana, tá com 80 anos e
tem uma rotina muito interessante. Ele
acorda com gratidão, come pratos
coloridos, faz exercício todo dia e come
um prato colorido.
Nesse estudo grande que eu tô
comentando, quem comeu mais
ultraprocessados no estudo teve 32%
menos chances de envelhecer com saúde.
Seria pelo menos três vezes de semana.
Denise
Bem, pessoal, tem mais alguma pergunta?
senão vou encerrar por aqui.
Bem, obrigado por terem participado ao
vivo, Denise e Maria Helena. Nós nos
vemos na semana que vem. Um abraço para
vocês.